Hollywood mourns the loss of Playboy
founder Hugh Hefner et can confirm the
iconic magazine publisher died on
Wednesday at home at the Playboy Mansion
he was 91 years old now family members
and celebrities are paying their
respects Hefner's 26 year old son Cooper
released a statement saying in part
quote my father lived an exceptional and
impactful life as a media and cultural
pioneer and a leading voice behind some
of the most significant social and
cultural movements of our time in
advocating free speech civil rights and
sexual freedom Kendra Wilkinson who
dated Hefner and appeared with him on
their reality series The Girls Next Door
told et quote have changed my life he
made me the person I am today I couldn't
be more thankful for our friendship and
our time together I will miss him so
much but he will be in my heart forever
Kim Kardashian who posed for the mag in
2007 tweeted her condolences so did
Paris Hilton along with some throwback
photos Jenny McCarthy former Playmate of
the Year in 1994 also tweeted about the
mogul thanking him for being a
revolutionary and changing so many
people's lives especially mine singer
The Weeknd tweeted rest in peace while
Rob Lowe called Hefner's death the end
of an era and Ryan Seacrest said he will
forever be remembered as the Hollywood
legend who lived life to the fullest